[Applause]
and night by night we will carry out my
pledge of engines
[Music]
the first draft of the script that i
read was
you know highly developed he and i
talked about all the characters but he
also
was incredible about
giving me the backstory i think that the
working relationship totally benefited
from having done both which and the
lighthouse with robert i mean he does an
incredible amount of his own research
obviously i started to read the sagas he
would you know explain certain things he
would say how they fit into the
characters that were in the script it's
a fantastic primer really you know for
him to give me and craig all of the
information all the actors as well so i
then
sort of start off with my own research
that is purely costume oriented uh the
materials you know the what is the
beginning and then where are we going to
find this stuff you know where where
does it come from the next part is to
then offload all of that information to
the costume department so everyone is on
the same page in terms of why we are
doing what we are doing if it's not a
script that you are stylizing the
costumes if it's script and a project
film
where authenticity is what you want to
immerse the audience in then that
becomes the first
level of looking at things and then
if there are problems within you know
the performance of the piece then you
need to sort of address those
as well because people have to work in
it people you know have to do take after
take after cake comfort was a huge thing
for alexander because
he's in every single scene he's on set
basically every day in very inclement
weather he has such the physicality is
is amazing he's crossing wet thatched
roofs he's on uneven ground he's in mud
he's fighting it's just never ending the
landscape changes and so you know he was
such a trooper amith is an interesting
character because he first see him as a
child and he's high status he has all
the trappings of a high status boy all
the color the excess the precious metals
the very specific tablet weaving all of
those things take a lot of time to make
and they therefore show a very high
status person and then once he leaves
perhaps he and goes to sea the next time
we see him is the adult version which is
where alexander picks up the story and
when we see him as a berserker initially
he is dressed in as i say a kind of land
of the roost uh eastern influenced
clothing we now see buttons you know
this is something that perhaps two
people in the audience might notice but
there are no buttons in dropsy it they
weren't used at that period at that
place and so now we move to land of the
roost which is where they were used then
we see him as his berserker character
his is unique in that he is a
combination of both
wolf and bear from there on actually for
the rest of the film it's kind of
interesting because
he is not wearing his own clothing he is
wearing either the disguise of a dead
slave man or he's wearing slave clothing
even though he he himself is highborn he
has different versions of slave clothing
we did barefoot shoes so that
slaves would appear to be barefoot and
often anya
amazingly said i'll just go barefoot we
then see amleth in in a couple of
different versions of elevated slave
slave after he saves gooner he becomes a
slave with privileges and then in the
end we see him as a viking man again but
it's in stolen clothing clothing that
olga has escaped with and for that last
outfit that we see
amethyst the beautiful blue cloak
is actually the same hand-woven wool
that his father arvindell wore in the
opening scenes orvan dills is the
natural sheep color two tones in woven
in a pattern and we dyed that same
fabric the beautiful blue that was the
same blue of the young prince's hat
again these are very very very subtle
echoes
helps the actors connects them it's
lovely for us in the costume department
to have that those threads you know that
kind of carried through robert loved it
the slav costumes for olga and all the
villagers male and female embroidery was
a huge cultural aspect to it because
women
embroidered the clothing for themselves
and their families with motifs at the
neck and the sleeves the upper arms the
lap and hem
to
ward off evil spirits yes but also more
than that it was a call to the gods and
so figuring out all of the motifs and
where to apply them was the first
kind of layer of that research but
if women are doing that for their own
families the slav witch is like the uber
writer and actually there's an
interesting fact that i learned which is
apparently the word for embroidery at
the period was the same as the word for
writing so what these women were doing
is they were writing a future praying
for a future encouraging a future and so
the slave witch was like the uber writer
so her costume had embroidery um in
spades and unlike olga and
omleth and
several of the other villagers who had
hand embroidered costumes in different
levels of distress
we did
machine embroidery for some of the slav
crowd
but then for the slav which we did
screened so we took photographs of the
embroidery hand embroidery and then
screened her shift
and what was interesting about that
whole process was that jaron who does
the most beautiful
moonlight lighting
and
natural lighting in dark interiors the
moonlight lighting meant that many of
the colors read
particularly and the embroidery was
meant to be in daylight it's red or
black and then red in geron's moonlight
lighting goes to black so we had to come
up with um pinks and grays which you
don't really see in the moonlight but if
you were to see photographs color
photographs of bjork
in her costume it's you know the the
colors are quite different i mean her
skirt has many many belts that are the
slav belts that are sewn together just
beautiful barley head dress
and the cowrie shells and bells which
were fertility and again the bells to
ward off evil spirits so hers is her
costume of york's costume the the cias
is
a kind of intense
magnification of all of those cultural
aspects the challenging scenes with
lighting were the warrior king because
he is literally in a dark um he's a
mound dweller in a underground burial
ship the textile choices for that had to
be very specific and and quite light so
i sort of went with a vibe of ash dust
dry
chalk
dry
light and and with as much kind of gold
or metallic thread
to
throw back any light that any available
light there was a piece of weaving
tablet reading in the british museum
that i saw what the archaeologists had
found were the gold threads obviously
the fibers had rotted and so it was just
really basically the gold in in lines in
a strip and then they did a recreation
of what they felt the actual piece of
woven material with fiber and gold would
have looked like and i took a little
video of that and that became my
inspiration if i can if i can imbue the
costumes in the banquet scene with that
you know twinkle
then that will be great i think that
they're you know with each of each film
the trust deepens the friendship deepens
with robert and he loves it you know
he's passionate